kabul fue la última en caer lo que
aceleró la retirada del país por parte
de las tropas de eeuu y la otan la toma
era tan inminente que el mandatario
afgano huyó hacia emiratos árabes y la
capital quedó en manos del talibán el 15
de agosto
es un placer para mí entregar el palacio
presidencial al talibán y que este
proceso se haya completado sin derramar
sangre como
muchos se agolparon en el aeropuerto
internacional de kabul esperando que los
militares extranjeros los evacuar
pero la situación se volvió una bomba de
tiempo y el 26 de agosto un miembro del
estado islámico se inmoló matando a más
de 170 personas entre ellos 13 soldados
estadounidenses las tropas
internacionales terminaron la retirada
un día antes de lo planeado
estoy aquí para anunciar la finalización
de nuestra retirada de afganistán y el
fin de la misión militar para evacuar a
ciudadanos estadounidenses ciudadanos de
terceros países y afganos vulnerables
el talibán continúan los combates en
panshir la única provincia que se
resistía a caer en sus manos hasta que
proclamó la victoria el 6 de septiembre
un día después anunciaron el nuevo
gobierno que busca reconocimiento
internacional en medio de un rechazo
reiterado debido al temor que generan
los abusos a los derechos humanos
especialmente los de las mujeres el
grupo talibán ahora busca convertir una
toma relámpago del poder en un gobierno
que perdure a pesar de las protestas
ciudadanas una profunda crisis económica
y las sequías que impulsan a miles a
buscar refugio en las ciudades el
programa mundial de alimentos de la onu
teme que los suministros puedan acabarse
para finales dejando a 14 millones de
personas en riesgo de hambruna